-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Lena Dunham.
So, this is a film.
You adapted it.
You also directed it.
It's been a while since you've
been in the director's chair.
I know it got rave reviews
in Toronto.
But was it exciting to get
behind the camera again?
-Yeah, it's my favorite place
to be.
It's my most favorite place
It's like that cheesy feeling
where you're like,
"Oh, I'm doing the thing that
I was brought here to do."
And it's adapting my favorite
book from when I was
10 years old, so I'm living all
kinds of fantasies come true.
And I got to move through
the medieval times
and basically experience
"Back to the Future"
but reverse but forward?
-It's funny because --
you know, I think of "Girls" as
this like, again, quintessential
New York show in the same way I
think of you as this sort of
quintessential New York,
you know, personality.
And here you are in London
and you make a film with
a very stacked British cast.
Did you find it
to be a departure?
Did you find them different
to direct at all?
-I love English actors.
Listen, I love all actors.
I respect what they do.
I worship every cast
I work with.
But I will tell you, like,
America around actors
is a little bit of
like a cult of personality.
It's about like showing up with
the cool 'tude.
And I would say in England,
it's --
I can't believe I just said
'tude like a 97-year-old man.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But in England it's more
like a cult of craft.
Like, those British actors,
like, it's not like,
"Oh, I think I'll learn my lines
in the hair and makeup chair,
let's play around."
They are not coming to play.
It's a military operation.
Like, you do not show up not
knowing what you're going to do
when you have a cast of people
who have been in
"Game of Thrones."
-Yeah.
-They're not --
-You had a lot of "Throne"-ers
in the show.
If people noticed in the clip,
we had -- which was --
It actually took me a minute
when I started watching this.
So that's your star.
-Bella Ramsey,
a.k.a. Lyanna Mormont.
-Yeah, Lyanna Mormont.
And I feel like we never
got to see -- You certainly show
us a lot more range
than she ever got
to show on "Game of Thrones."
-Well, yes. This was --
-Not a lot of comedy
from Lyanna Mormont.
-I believe my dad's quote was,
"You cast that
tiny scary person."
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
And then he asked, "Did she give
you a lot of 'tude?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly --
-Because he was of the age
that you used 'tude.
-And I will say
that she is lovely,
gave me zero 'tude,
and is a complete genius.
So yeah, we got her.
-Uh-huh.
And then three more
"Thrones"-ers
at least, I counted.
-Oh, yeah.
So that is --
Let me get this right.
That's that tiny guy
who jumped off the thing.
-Yeah, yeah. Right.
-I just watched once through,
you guys.
I loved it,
but it's very intense.
-Yeah. Tommen.
-Yes, Tommen.
-Yeah.
-Little Prince Tommen.
-This gentleman
has a very important --
all of the names are --
like, I could make up a
"Game of Thrones" name for him.
-Do it.
-His name is
Vandrik Katarsavie.
[ Laughter ]
-Katarsavie, yes.
Of the Katarsavies.
-Of the Katarsavies.
-Their crest was
a crab holding a sword.
-That's exactly right.
Of the crab-sword-holding
Katarsavies.
And then that is, I mean,
British legend David Bradley.
And if you have not seen David
Bradley in full knight's armor
looking for a Wi-Fi signal,
then you have not lived.
-Oh, that's great.
-Just walking around base camp.
[ Laughter ]
Clanking around.
-And that's Walder.
I remember that one.
He's Walder.
-And then also Ralph Ineson,
who I believe plays --
well, I know that he --
his last name
in it is...Kratolanium.
No, I don't know.
I can't remember.
But Ralph Ineson is
another "Thrones"-er
who was in our cast.
-And it must have also --
I mean, to do a period piece
film in England is just
one more added wonderful
element.
-I just have to say,
like, you just stand there
and you're like, "As a New York
Jewess, this is not
where I thought
I would find myself."
[ Laughter ]
"And I feel blessed."
Like, not a bagel in sight.
[ Laughter ]
But a corset everywhere
you look.
-There you go.
-And I love that.
-That is a departure
and we are all lucky
that you made it on our behalf.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It's always so great.
-Always a joy.
-You guys, that's Lena Dunham.
"Catherine Called Birdy" is
in select theaters next Friday
and on Prime Video October 7th.
We'll be right back with Jo Koy.